vie mort
enfants enfance travail créer
mère mère
[Musique]
bonne soirée à tous et merci pour
venir
mon partenaire marco moore a repensé
le futur
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à travailler dans
une entreprise comme la nôtre
vous avez un besoin mais activez-en un
solution tu couches avec elle
ils sont venus pour eux un retour de mon
rêves la première étape pour résoudre un
le problème a commencé
Je ne me définis pas, je ne veux pas parler d'elle
et d'eux il n'y a pas d'autres femmes
nous avons tous des secrets que personne ne devrait
savoir
[Musique]
son frère a besoin qu'il pense à l'aise
Aussi mon frère est tout ce que j'ai
sait ce qui t'arrive que tu es le même
quels camps ou environnement est nécessaire
la stabilité émotionnelle a prolongé la personne
pour m'éloigner de lui oui oui je le suis
[Musique]
avez-vous déjà eu des relations sexuelles avec
inconnu
[Musique]
toutes les chansons qui porte son visage
caché
maintenant hors de cette société déjà
markoff l'enfer avec ça tu sais quoi
c'est l'enfer
Je ne me souviens de rien de ce qui s'est passé la nuit dernière
[Musique]